Google stadia is dying and handing out
refunds at its funeral we're talking
about that and more on today's Gamespot
news
Google has announced that its Cloud
streaming service stadia will officially
be shut down on January 18 2023. all
stadia Hardware purchases made through
the Google Store will be refunded
including games and add-on content
purchased from that specific storefront
past Pro subscriptions to the service
will not be included in the list of
refundable stadia purchases however in a
blog post stadia VP Phil Harrison said
that the technology pioneered by the
service will be used in other Google
services such as YouTube Google Play and
augmented reality projects the company
also plans to make the underlying
technology available to Industry
Partners stadium was first revealed in
early 2019 at that Year's GDC event and
officially launched in November of that
same year the streaming service had an
impressive number of third-party Games
available with big names such as
Assassin's Creed Odyssey cyberpunk 2077
and doom Eternal in its Library Google
also had big plans for exclusive titles
on stadia and began investing in its own
game studios but by February 2021 it had
shut down that Division and announced it
would no longer develop its own games in
the last few years stadia also began to
face some stiff competition Amazon
entered the cloud gaming Market with
Luna and Microsoft began working on its
own streaming project that leveraged its
own impressive library of titles Game
Pass subscription and Cloud Gaming
Technologies following the news of
stadia coming to an end many users in
possession of the services controller
took to places like Reddit to ask Google
for unlocked Bluetooth capabilities this
is something the community has been
requesting for years but now that the
service is ending it would go a long way
to making sure the hardware doesn't just
become trash for many gamers the good
news is that the stadio controller works
for other platforms like steam when used
wired so at least that's always an
option if Google doesn't unlock Wireless
capabilities let me know in the comments
if you were one of stadius Die Hard
users and give me some of your favorite
moments with the platform meanwhile over
on PlayStation Sony is preparing to
launch PlayStation Stars a new loyalty
program that anyone with the PlayStation
account can join it does not require a
PlayStation Plus Membership and will
first debut in Asia today September 29th
North America and South America on
October 5th and Europe and Australia on
October 13th PlayStation Stars works by
rewarding players who complete campaigns
and activities like a monthly check-in
AKA just playing any game or earning
specific trophies rewards include
loyalty points and digital Collectibles
that are notably not nftes there are
four status levels in PlayStation Stars
determined by the number of non-common
trophies you obtain and the number of
full game purchases in the PlayStation
Store the higher the status level the
more rewards and benefits you get as for
those who do have PlayStation Plus
memberships subscription payments do not
count towards loyalty points one of the
rewards causing a bit of a discussion on
the web today now that the service is
available in Asia is better customer
service as reported by VGC the level
four tier perks include a collectible
and the promise of quote when contacting
PlayStation customer support you will be
given priority in the chat order the
discussion around this isn't too
positive so I'm not going to dive deep
into the tweets and reactions but I do
want to know what you're thinking in the
comments below so let me know and I'll
see you tomorrow
foreign
[Music]